and he's on this uh this uh like fighter
advocacy thing like uh what do you what
do you make about a Fighters Union yeah
type deal yeah something along those
lines he hasn't been extremely clear but
yes he wants to have something for the
fighter so they can come in and they can
they can bargain a little more
collectively I know that uh uh medical
benefits are are a huge one I've heard a
number of guys say that and when they do
say it I don't want to tease them like
that seems like a nice thing to want
people to have more I like that but it
does concern me but wait do you guys not
have it because Dana didn't get it for
you like he's your father do you not
have you guys not know it's at one phone
call and you get set up and you know I
do wonder about that with like Francis
Nagano when he was like yeah that was
one of the things I'm arguing about like
you're making eight million a fight or
whatever that is it's 400 a month for
health insurance like you can't just pay
for the year right but I don't know I
mean maybe there's other things in the
contract that he wasn't talking about
but like you're you're a independent
contractor yes it's just right it's a
blanket statement of every independent
contractor in the United States very
clear that that whole hang up was about
being allowed to boxer sure so the
health insurance is a real red herring
in that conversation it's uh got nothing
to do with it and by the way and by the
way what what do you predict there I
mean so yes it's about the boxing match
and now Tyson Fury has come out and says
I want to do the boxing match but we
don't have a promoter that's got
distribution or or a pocketbook or a
ring for that matter so so how are they
going to do that because I didn't see a
value in angano I saw a value in the
sitting UFC heavyweight champion with
Dana White Carnival Barker in your
corner if you take that out of it I feel
you took the value out Am I Wrong
um you're not wrong and I think that the
what you're pointing to is is what is so
wrong with the Dynamics of boxing people
say about look at how much money these
boxers make and I would say that and
look what happened to the sport because
it's so disorganized and and there isn't
a a promotion that's really that got a
control of it and that's why the UFC is
doing so well I would say that the
biggest problem with uh an engineer Fury
fight
is the fact that in ghanu had to wrestle
his way to Victory against Cyril gone
like uh the the Striking wasn't there
against Cyril gone so what's to make us
believe that the Striking is at the
level that's going to make it worth
watching Fury and then gone yeah I see
that as problematic as well the the fact
and great job too and Gano for having
that weapon that we didn't know we had
turned into that tool digging deep I
mean he deserves a lot of credit for
that win over surreal but I saw that too
we're not talking about surreal versus
uh Tyson and surreal was clearly the
better Striker right so I think that's
an interesting spot and I it does
concern me for Francis I I don't think
because it all comes to Genesis it's
Conor McGregor fighting Floyd Mayweather
but some guys seem to be missing Conor
McGregor did not get 100 million to
fight Floyd Mayweather the two divisions
simultaneous Champion with Dana White in
your corner got a hundred million
dollars to box and I I feel that perhaps
Francis is is missing that and you know
he sure seems like a gentleman to me
Francis seems like a very nice guy but
this one is a it's a miss and we don't
know how old he is he's at least 36
years old and that time goes fast now
you gotta bum me on top of it man yeah
you're taking that 8 million in my
opinion you don't know how old he is
yeah what do you mean well he so where
he comes from it's very tough to get
records it's it's very tough and so he's
saying he's 36. he doesn't even know
himself well I I don't he could take a
great uh offense to that I don't want to
go down the road of offending him I'm
just sharing with you he claims to be
36. I'll I'll see you that he's at least
36. he could be older than that though
and I'll tell you in this sport man it
it changes it changes quick you know he
was blessed with with some very
beautiful DNA but it does catch you at
some point at the same time though the
last thing to go is power yep and so
heavyweights are going to last longer
than the lighter guys it sounds like you
can just count the tree rings on his
tree trunk legs sure yeah the
um the real pisser about it though is
that when he did emerge against surreal
as a wrestler that we did did not know
he was he became a lot more interesting
in MMA and now he's just left like you
know you really wanted to see it but the
the
Evolution continue with in ghanu oh
Francis versus Jon Jones I mean for our
entire industry you co-promote any way
that you want to do it that is the
biggest match our industry could could
produce that that was something very
special John taking three years to go
put on the size you know I disagree with
John on that John was saying I need to
weigh 240. say this but I gotta weigh
240 to beat these heavyweights I think
he could have walked right in their way
in 206 and beaten all those heavyweights
I I don't think that John has ever fully
understood quite how good John is
I was getting ready to I was getting
ready to fight him and I was on a
conference call with him he was talking
about the things that he had to do to
beat me and he was talking about the
things he had to do to be the best light
heavyweight ever who he was saying was
Tito Ortiz and I'm listening to this
going
there's none of those things that are
true you're going to kill me and you
would kill Tito too and he was like 21.
yeah I'm on my phone yeah that's right
he's a 21 year old kid I gotta go show
him this respect but I knew he was
better than he knew he was I I guess
maybe that's my point and uh
I think that that's one of his strengths
I think the fact that he does still get
scared that he does uh you know still
still see these guys in ways that they
could win I think that's one of the
things that keeps John Sharp but yeah
we'll only have to wonder what would
have happened if those two would have
fought that'd be a special night I mean
I wonder if Jon Jones watched Israel out
of Sonya go up to light heavyweight and
just get held down by John blahovich and
think oh I don't want to do that let me
put on somewhere oh it could be you know
I know I know that John shares the
practice room with a lot of very
meaningful heavyweights uh Travis Brown
comes to mind Alice drover and comes to
mind uh Andre orlovsky you know but
these guys were Champions these guys had
real good and and they'll be the first
to tell you you know we we couldn't
really deal with him he moved too well
he was too long so I bring that up
really as a compliment to John I think
that he also burned three good years of
his life I think there's some some real
good moments to have there and I can't
relate I was never I was never good
enough as John I wanted to be world
champion John won so many World
Championships he gave one of them back
he goes here you take it I couldn't
imagine giving one back but uh I mean
that's another level of success or even
Francis to walk away and give a belt
back I couldn't even imagine I was
critical at the time when uh when when
he vacated the belt I I said
um
the the tell for me was that we had seen
so many champ Champs up to that point
the goal is Champ champ sure there's no
nobody ever gave back a bill to be a
single Champion another division sure so
that indicated to me
that uh I don't know it was weird and I
remember too because uh you know we were
out in Albuquerque with Jon Jones you
know and staying at his house and you
know at the at the time he was uh fresh
off of his controversial win over
Dominic Reyes uh he was doing his uh I'm
gonna go save the world with The Care
Project wrong and he invited us out to
be a part of that and um you know he was
really outspoken about you know there's
not enough to pay I want more money
and uh I told him I said I think that
the uh the way to get more money
is
to understand that everybody wants to
see you lose and your last
fights were so so close you know people
even arguing that you didn't win them
that people really believe
now is the chance to see Jon Jones lose
sure that's the leverage you know
and uh to your point three years away
yeah
well that's what's keeping the Jake the
Jake Paul uh experiment uh above float
too is that people want to see him get
beat yeah and yeah if John would steer
into that just a little bit I think he's
got a very favorable matchup with
surreal I think that uh I really like to
know what happened with Stipe I
personally just like to see Stipe in
there more Stipe believes he's gonna
fight the winner I I don't know if I'm
if I'm bullish on that you know if you
couldn't get the fight with John now
you've waited 14 months to get it he win
if you can't get it now what's going to
be different six months from now so
let's see how that all plays out but I
would like to leave you guys with one
thought on that which is when John left
three years ago he he put you talk about
Burning Bridges he puts he put C4 all
over that bridge he didn't know how to
detonate it but if he would have known
he would have blown that bridge up I
mean he was not coming back and
everything's gonna be changing you're
going to give everybody different things
or you'll never see me again
he's now back and with a raise and into
a world title fight Francis was a
gentleman we if we're going to tell the
story accurately we do have to say that
about Francis he never used profanity he
never raised his voice you know Francis
never made any threats and he's a very
intimidating guy and my only point being
if John can come back after what he did
Francis can come back too and if I was
to make a prediction he's going to right
yeah Francis has a rude awakening come
in and I will tell you I don't think he
meant to disrespect Dana White but to
sit down and tell Dana there's problems
with Dana's contract after everything
that Dana did and the way Dana changed
the sport now you're gonna sit down and
you're gonna tell Dana I mean Stephen
let's just change this Dana sits down
with you and tells you how to throw a
jab then he tells you how to throw a
cross and he tells you uh how much you
should be eating and sleeping and you go
leave the fighting to me you bring the
bells and whistles I'll bring the action
it's like exactly so why are you telling
me how to do the business side of this
you're not going to change my contracts
you're not going to change the way that
I do things
Francis wants to have a meeting before
every single fight he has and I know he
doesn't mean that is rude he thinks
that's a respect but there's not enough
time to have those kind of meetings Dana
puts on 11 fights every single Saturday
it is so disrespectful for you to imply
that we're gonna sit down and talk about
talking we got to get things done
quickly right
and that's just the reality if you don't
understand that you're being rude to me
even if you're not trying to be but you
are
what kind of a time frame do you think
um we can see
the boxing not work as well for Francis
as he hopes it might and for him to come
back to the UFC I'm concerned with that
six months sure that's a great guess so
Tyson Fury came out last night just in
case you guys didn't see this ties of
fear comes out last night he says Hey
Francis and Gano I know that you're no
longer under contract with the UFC so
let's you and me fight and they've
always talked that they're gonna go make
a sport up they're not just gonna box
they're not gonna do MMA they're gonna
create something so Tyson laid out what
that is he said we're gonna do it in a
cage we're gonna do a four ounce gloves
it's gonna be Queen Berry rules and Mike
Tyson is going to be the special referee
and it's like okay let's see
I grew up with guys that would ask the
girl out but but then they'd put LOL hey
we should go to a movie this weekend lol
it's like oh but that's what Tyson's now
done putting Mike Tyson and there's a
special guest referee was laying out a
plan that you'd really like to work but
you're not sure anybody's gonna sign off
on it so then you went too far with it
and I just thought it was psyllium going
Tyson if you can't get this done if you
can't find somebody with distribution
and a platform to to scoop this up this
is a huge miss this is a massive massive
mistake and why are you guys going off
to make out your own sport yeah like
what's on the line your reputation has
got to be on the line or his reputation
it can't be we're doing this for nothing
it's got to be one or the other do
Queens Bears or do unified rules
Queensbury just means western boxing
okay yeah they like to call it
Queensbury if you're a real prick to
show that you're a boxing historian
you'll throw out the term like
Queensbury which is precisely why I just
it just means western boxing okay yeah
man it's really interesting I I hope
that that Scott's right six months I
mean it's like with Dana White's always
trying to plan something or somebody's
like why wants to start their own thing
he's like go for it do you have any idea
how hard it is to start something like I
mean that that documentary three letters
I mean you saw how hard it was to get
the UFC off the ground it's like well
you're just gonna do that now right
um he doesn't know he's being
disrespectful Scott he does Francis
doesn't know he's being a jerk about
this telling Dana we're gonna sit down
and talk before every time I have a
fight Dana's got 556 guys under
contracts he puts on 11 fights every
Saturday there's no one that he can sit
and talk with the hotel before we check
everybody and I can't I'm not going to
talk to you every week the the airplanes
before every plane ticket I'm not gonna
talk to all of them and I can't talk
different I gotta be able to text you I
gotta go be able to do a step further
which is something that Dana did last
night he goes to a press conference and
he announces Glover to share versus uh
Jamal Hill for the light heavyweight
championship he hadn't spoken to those
guys they had never agreed to fight each
other they never agreed to go five
rounds I never agreed it was going to be
a title fight they were going to meet in
Brazil they knew he could count on him
he goes to a press conference he's in a
jam he's got a light heavyweight fight
that goes to a draw that wasn't was
supposed to do that he goes and makes an
announcement and they both make the boss
look good that's that's what you do if
you're actually on board Francis wants
to sit down and talk he doesn't know
he's being rude but he is that's
extremely rude and the world doesn't
work that way we don't have time who's
giving him that advice I have the
foggiest idea he dropped his he dropped
his manager he dropped his manager as a
guy with CAA Markell who done a very
good job and then he was getting advice
from many people but he actually handed
it himself which is one of the reasons
this was a problem one of the demands
that Francis made on top of health
insurance he demanded that there be a
fighter Advocate at every meeting like
the one they're having and Dana's
looking around going Francis first I
don't give guys meetings but I'm giving
you one secondly you didn't bring an
advocate you could have brought an
advocate you didn't bring you fired your
advocate so you're telling me to provide
an advocate for all the guys first off
if I provide the guy he's going to be
he's gonna be helping me not you and
secondly why didn't you bring one if
they're so important and that was just a
little bit of the conflict that they ran
into where at some point you're looking
around going man I this isn't worth it
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole plus Stephen's butthole
destroyer and Stevo's butt wipes for
your butthole it's the butthole bundle
available on Amazon right now
yeah dude